so why are some motion designers able to
quickly concept style frames while
others are unable to even gather
their thoughts or how do some motion
designers easily design
style frames while others can't draw a
stick figure to save their life
and why are some people able to deliver
pro level style frames very quickly
while others are spending countless
hours on
mediocre design in this free workshop
i'm going to share the answers to these
questions and more so you too can design
pro level style frames
hey there my name is cameron i'm the
founder of motion science i'm also the
creator of stylecraft and i'm
a pro motion designer with over two
decades that's right
two decades of pro experience welcome to
my brand new video workshop
how to design style frames in this first
video we're going to
discover a simple process for concepting
style frames this is
very important and it's immediately
going to help you
improve and move forward in creating
style frames
once you get this process down you're
going to start experiencing an overall
easier approach to style frame design
and it's really easy
so today i'm going to show you the
concepting process where we're going to
collect your thoughts we're going to
gather assets for style frame design
so that you can have an easy process
for the design process an easy process
for style frame design so if you're a
junior motion designer but you aren't
sure how to really start or you're a
mid-level motion designer that isn't
able to create at a pro level
stay with me because you're going to
discover how motion designers like
you and me can easily create style
frames by
first starting with concepting
this is critical and i'm going to
explain it
because right now you might think you
have to be a design
prodigy to be considered a pro but
that's
absolutely not true you might have
already tried the concept style frames
in the past and it just didn't quite
work out the way you'd hoped
there's many reasons for this one of
them may be because you're not
a master of illustrator neither am i or
maybe you didn't go to a design school
neither did i
so you may be wondering if
i can't draw if i can't become a master
of illustrator if
i did not attend design school how can i
really design style frames
and trust me i get it i've heard that
little voice in my
of doubt in my head and it says
hey cameron you're an imposter you're
not a true designer
but honestly i'm here today to show you
that you can do this
anyone can do this and i want to
demystify the process of style frame
concepting for you
so that this can help save you a lot of
time
and frustration so in this first video
i'm going to share a simple process
i developed after years of trial and
error
this is something that if you experience
resistance
when starting style from design this is
going to help serve as a
tremendous resource to eliminate that
frustration and that resistance
and help you lay a solid foundation for
your style frame design
the reason i'm sharing this with you is
because i developed this
framework because i saw so many motion
designers
become completely frustrated from the
start and kind of go into a panic mode
while trying to get their thoughts in
order and to be fully transparent
this was my story too so when i started
out as a freelance motion designer
one day i was asked to design style
frames for a company called digital
kitchen
and like i said that was a brand new
freelancer i was really good at
animation but i had never designed style
frames before and digital kitchen
wanted me to deliver a set of style
frames to them within a few days
i wasn't even sure i could even do this
and i was up front with the art director
about this because i had never designed
style frames before and to be totally
honest i doubted
um that i could do this like i said i
was honest with that art director
because i didn't attend art school like
this this creative director
i knew that he had a lot of design
experience and and he was looking
for someone who could could also design
at a high level
so on top of that i figured
i had to have a gift of design and i
didn't know if i had that or not i had
never taken a drawing class
i had never taken any type of art class
in my life
so if any of this sounds familiar let me
tell you
um i know what it's like to to doubt
yourself and
feel like you're an imposter and that
you can't do this
i questioned whether i could even do it
but i was tired of spinning my wheels
and i knew that
if i was to lay a solid foundation
through concepting
this was going to be the key to getting
what i was after
in style frames so i set out to make it
happen
so once i got past my objections and i
began
really investing myself and and and
laying out this concepting
framework i started releasing massive
growth
in my design my style frame design got
much quicker
and it got a lot easier to do and
essentially i said i accomplished what i
set out to do
so now i can design cell frames very
quickly
and i want to teach that to you
so to go through the process of
designing style frames we have to start
with concepting so if you're ready to
create more beautiful looking style
frames
you're going to love what i'm about to
teach you so like i said the purpose of
this is to help you quickly get moving
in the right direction so that you're
not spinning your wheels
and you're not getting frustrated and
you're just laying a solid foundation
for style frame design so are you ready
let's do this okay so when we are
concepting style frames a lot of times
what happens is
is a client will come to us and it's a
client it's an agency
it's a direct client it's an agency it's
a production company whoever it is that
you're working for
they're going to come to you and they're
going to say here is our our creative
brief
okay and a creative brief can be as
something as simple as one sentence
it could be one paragraph it could be
two paragraphs it could be
a one-page pdf it could be a 10-page pdf
it could be a single image it could be a
video
a creative brief can be a lot of
different things
sometimes the client will come to you
and say here's
what we're doing sometimes the clients
can be very um abstract
kind of secretive about what they're
doing and that sometimes happened to me
when i was working for production
companies they'd say listen we have a
client
um they this is who the client is
and like let's say it was disney right
and disney wants to do
a a piece about a video game but we
can't tell you what the name of the
video game is
we can't tell you what it's about we can
give you some general ideas
and we need you to create it and
that is more of a you know it's a it's
more challenging to come up with an idea
but sometimes the client will also come
to you and say hey
we have an idea for this
and here's an image here's something to
go off of and you kind of have free
reign to go
so for this particular and i've talked
about creative briefs
in more detail and other videos i have
out there
in my courses like stylecraft
and on social media channels so i'm not
going to go and
show you a creative brief but what i'm
going to do here is i i said to myself
i gave myself a creative brief for the
video you're watching now i said i want
to create
something around the idea of
the cold war okay and
with everything going on in the world
today um
it's been an interesting challenging
time for the last several years
actually the last several decades and
the cold war has
always really um intrigued me
so i thought okay why don't we do
something with the cold war so i
start with an idea okay and this could
be anything
but i'm going to pick an idea around the
cold war
okay now what you're seeing here is a is
a program called work
flowy and workflowy is um very cheap
and it's an app that i've used for years
and i absolutely love it
now there's a thousand apps out there
there's a hundred thousand apps out
there
for helping you to get your ideas in
order some people
prefer flow charts i don't prefer a
flowchart
i like this app so what's cool about
this app is i can go into a board
mode like this or a bullet point mode
which a lot of times i work in but we're
going to start with an idea
and i what i do is i write down okay
here's my basic idea i'm going to do the
cold war
and something about the atomic age to
the space age and i came up with the
atomic age the space age because i did a
little bit of
googling about what is what are some
different aspects of the cold war and i
found out the cold war
um actually went on for many many many
years i always think of the cold war as
something that happened in the 70s and
80s well it actually started way before
then
and what i do is i like to use sites
like wikipedia and
when i'm researching i i just begin with
my idea and i just type in things like
cold war right so again there's a lot of
different ways you can do this
i start with wikipedia and i started
kind of going through some different
things about the
some different aspects of the cold war
and
pretty much settled on an idea i what i
did is i i take some of these paragraphs
of texts
and i can just copy command c on them on
a mac
and here in my program i can just
command v
and paste and i've got um
like let's say it's a paragraph that was
inspiring to me right and i just do a
little bit of research
about the topic i've picked so you can
see there's several
paragraphs here but once i when i start
researching the cold war i
i really was was uh
focusing in on more of the space and the
war
side of the cold war because there's
different aspects of the cold war
and and that just happened because i was
just going through and
you know finding out different
information on wikipedia here and some
other sites off google about
what what is the cold war so that's the
first thing you want to do you want to
start with an idea
and you want to research that idea and
you want to just kind of hone in
on certain aspects of that idea that
really stand out to you
okay the next thing i do and that could
come from
you creating the idea yourself
or it can come from a creative brief
from a client it's the same process
if a client tells you we want to focus
on the cold war it's got to be about the
atomic age moving into the space age
well that's even easier because now i
can just research
that specifically and start finding out
different things about the cold war
so what i like to do next is i like to
start researching certain sites
that you see here for ideas and
inspiration
to help me kind of push my ideas
in a direction so everything in in
design has already been done before
okay there's nothing that comes out
that's brand new
and it's never been done before and
we've never seen it before
what's unique about what you design is
how
you take how what your spin on that
approach is
right and you just have to be you have
to be a creative person you have to
think outside the box and that's the the
my most favorite part is actually just
getting very creative here
and just finding things that uh that
really stand out to me and that i'm
drawn to and i and
can put my own spin on so what i like to
do is go to these different sites like
pinterest behance
instagram google reddit there's a lot
more
um inspirational sites research sites
that
inspire me to create okay so
the first one here is pinterest okay and
i'm actually on
my motion science board for pinterest if
you don't follow motion science
on pinterest i would recommend that you
do
i put a lot of pins up every single week
i put pens up from motion science
the work that is created through motion
science also work that i find highly
inspirational
from the world of pinterest and i just
create boards and i add
pens those boards and so you can get a
lot of really good inspiration here
some of these boards are pretty basic
and i
you know kind of change things around
but i a lot of times i start with my
pinterest boards because
these are places these are images that
have
really inspired me for some particular
reason that i've
inspired me enough that i have decided
to come back and
pin this okay so what i like to do is
start here in my
pinterest board and just find
um imagery or
animations that inspire me to kind of
push me in a direction
okay and there's a lot of places i go a
lot of times all if i'm working on title
design
which is you know to me title design is
anything that's imagery involving
typography
okay and these pieces are going to do
that so i would go into my title design
board and i would start looking at
different
titles i've saved and what about them
is interesting to me okay so i'm gonna
use a board like pinterest
i'm going to use a site like behance
um also what's great about these two
sites is if i don't see anything off the
top
that really inspires me you know i'll
just go in here and maybe just type in
something like
cold war design
or cold war graphic design so
immediately
this stuff is just really cool right and
it's stuff that inspires me
to make something of my own so i would
look at things like let's say this image
right here
for instance what about this image is
interesting to me well
it's it's the way that the texture of
the american flag
was used inside of this type okay so
that stands out to me
i like this image a lot as well it's the
repetition
of these uh guns uh
in their alignment and how they're
pointing at this guy it's very
interesting to me
so that's what i would do i'd also go to
behance i would search out
the same type of stuff maybe cold war
design and see what people come up with
i also love instagram for this kind of
stuff
um instagram is it's a little more
challenging
to search things out here on instagram
but
i always am using instagram as creative
inspiration to me
for um ways that i want to push my own
design work
i also love to go to reddit okay and
reddit
um reddit is a love hate thing for me
reddit sometimes for the most most of
the time i should say
uh reddit drives me crazy and
some of the posts on here drive me crazy
but uh there are times that i find
inspiration on reddit i follow the after
effects community
a cinema 4d community motion design and
motion graphics
so i follow four subreddits here on
on reddit that sometimes inspire me to
create work uh also there's google right
google's very um you know i mean we all
know what google is right so i'll
sit here and i'll type out um
cold war let's say images
and you can see here immediately this
stuff's really interesting to me
um that's really cool it's you know more
propaganda style stuff but uh
really dig that stuff so what i'm going
to do is i'm going to start
creating references which is my next
step
of things that inspire me and a lot of
times
for me creative references end up being
one of two things it could be a mood
board
which a mood board is something as
simple as taking imagery
into photoshop and just creating one
giant board inside of photoshop
and just pasting these images like let's
say this image here
into photoshop another image from
instagram
and just lay them all out side by side
just as an inspirational mood board
i also like to post video links here
for animation pieces that inspire me and
i'm looking at these to see
okay what about this is inspiring to me
so i love
i'm like this this is a very short piece
it's only seven eight seconds long
but i really like the layout i like the
use of tape
i like the fingerprint effect that's
happening here
i like the color scheme the color
palette
the different textures being used any of
you who have followed motion science for
any amount of time
know that i absolutely love textures and
textures are a huge part of my work
so this is the kind of stuff i'm looking
at and i'm
i'm constantly looking at these pieces
wondering okay how is this
why is this inspirational to me and what
about it
do i absolutely love and what about it
can i use my own work okay
so that's the confession tapes next i've
got one here
for the manhattan project promo design
so what i really like about
this set of style frames is again the
texture like the tape texture a lot the
way the type is laid out
the tape over the eyes the grid pattern
back here
some of this texture i like the white
overlays
here and again the logo here some really
interesting
uh design elements here i like the the
broken glass
the texture here on the side click on
this third one
pop it up the endless scare so this one
is in motion
i always thought this piece was really
interesting
and just like how it uses like this torn
type of texture
the type again little birds the moving
texture there now
what we're doing with stop frame is
we're not animating this but you have to
look at this
even though it's moving i want you to
look at you know when they were
designing this
uh this would obviously have been like a
style frame here right so when you're
designing style frames you're thinking
about
the big picture of the animation right
and that would have been a style frame
so i'm looking at the layout of that i
really like the redacted text a lot i've
always liked
that type of um elements this is cool
too
and then i've got a fourth example here
hbo manhunt
this has been around for a long time
again i like the texture and the type
the layout i'm looking at all this
layout here so i'm not looking so much
at the camera motion
moving across these but i'm looking at
the way that i like the red type a lot
so i'd probably like to incorporate that
um some different elements here i like
the way that the type the alignment of
the type is here
how it's all top aligned um and then the
black
and white with just a subtle bit of red
red type here
so you get the idea i just will pull up
different creative references like this
i'll copy and paste them into my
creative reference folder here
and i can always come back and look at
this to decide okay
what do i like from this piece what i
want to pull from this one what do i
want to pull for this one
next what i'm going to do is i'm going
to start looking for assets right
and actually before i do that what i
like to do is i just like to type them
out here
so i'm just typing out different assets
from the different pieces i found that i
really
were drawn to we saw the tape the
fingerprint the paper tears redacted
text
one to three photos i don't remember
actually why i put that down here
um maybe i'm just saying okay i know
what it was
i'm looking for just some basic photos
to use for base elements which i like to
you know when i get into photo bash
designing that will play into this
i like the layout for manhunt
a russian flag usa flag again this is
pulling from the wikipedia
stuff like the reference material here
in the copy they talk about russia a lot
the usa it's obviously the cold wars
between russia and the usa
maybe a blue versus red type of element
again the flags a u2 spy plane this is
being
pulled from this text in here uh
stalin which was the leader of russia
a map an eastern european american maps
a mushroom cloud because we talk about
the atomic age right and the atomic age
i always think of like the mushroom
clouds with the
atomic bombs going off uh a line of
pointed missiles on usa
moved to appointed missiles on the ussr
this is getting more into animation kind
of stuff but this i always think about
animation when i'm designing style
frames so i'm just going to list out all
the different assets
that i want here and obviously there's
textures right
i'm not going to list out specific
textures but i know based on
these different examples that there's a
lot of texture going on even in these
you can see the texture happening
right texture is a main a key
element in design and i absolutely love
texture so i'm just going to look for
textures
in general um you know just like
chalkboards like one of my favorite ones
is going to be
chalkboard right so i'll write down
chalkboard
i also want to look for some grid
elements
grid textures
maybe some stone texture
maybe some concrete texture but i like
to just write these out
and just you want more assets than
you're actually going to use
and the more you have to work with the
better now you don't want to overdo it
you don't want to
go move forward and say hey i'm going to
design two style frames which is what
we're gonna do
and have a hundred elements right that's
too many
but maybe 20 to 25 elements maybe
that'll be good
i also want to look for things like
newspaper
clippings that's something that came to
me
during the reference stage of this um i
should also mention that we are going to
design two style frames right i want two
style frames because when we're
designing style frames
a lot of times we'll be asked to uh
give one idea and then another idea
two separate ideas right they're still
having to do with the cold war
but i want to show two different
approaches two different style frames
and then a lot of times you know style
frame designers there's multiple style
frame designers
hired for a job because everyone has
their own style so for me
for motion science i'm going to create
two different style frames so
i'm going to take all these different
elements and create two stop frames
next i'm going to do is since i have a
list of assets now
i'm going to go to some of my favorite
sites and start pulling some of these
assets
so some of my favorite asset sites are
google
which you see up here envato elements
free pick
and turbo squid right and there's also
like a cg trader
if i'm getting more into the 3d assets
i'm going to start using some of these
turbosquid and cgtrader and things like
that
but there's there's a hundred more sites
right you have your favorites these are
just ones that are
my go to and a lot of times when i'm
using google as an asset site it's going
to lead me to other
uh creative sites where i can pull
assets from so the way i like to work is
i don't draw right we talked about i
don't know how to draw i've never taken
an art class
i do a process called photo bashing
and we're going to talk about that in
the next video but what we're going to
do is we're
going to find assets we're going to find
photos
we're going to find vector elements
we're going to find 3d models if we need
that from sites like google
and vato elements free pick turbosquid
and cgtrader
so just to give you an idea what i would
do here is i'm on google we'll start
with that
and i just cracked my
iphone screen which is why that's in
here
but we're going to let's look up like
let's say you two
spy plane right that was one of my
assets i wrote down
and i know the youtube spy plane was a
big
piece of the cold war with the u.s
spying so
what i like to do is i'll go into images
and here in images i also like to go to
my tools
and the first thing i'm going to do is
i'm going to usage rights and i'm going
to say labeled for
reuse with modification or label for
reuse
now if you're not going to design style
frames for commercial use
you can do a non-commercial here or you
can just leave this off completely if
this is something for you internally
but if this is something that's ever
going to go commercial you want to have
it labeled for reuse with modification
or labeled for reuse
okay that's just a safe way to go
sometimes i will also come into size
and i'll say i want large or i'll put in
a custom size to have very big
i like to work with larger images it's
just a little bit easier
to work with a larger image versus
having a tiny image of having to scale
it up and it's not looking so great
so that is the two keys is you want a
large size
you want reuse with modification
or reuse and what i'll do is i'll just
start going through and scrolling
through these and finding
youtube planes that are interesting to
me
and a lot of times i'm just going to
pull down multiple versions of those
youtube planes
and just start building um an asset
library
okay envato elements let's talk about
that
one this is a site i have a subscription
to
and i don't remember what i pay by
paying an annual subscription and what
it gives me
access to is stock video templates music
sound effects
graphics photos so on and so forth so i
could again i could come in here
i could find assets like in the photos
and the stock videos
video typically you don't want to use in
style frame design because you're going
to take a
video and then take a still frame from
that video sometimes you have to do that
but you know this is great for even
fonts things like that so maybe in here
i'm going to
search out like uh this is a great place
to find textures
right and i'm going to go in and maybe
go into these
photos and find some textures i want to
use
and start downloading those and just
start building an asset library
this also brings up a great one i didn't
put down here
on my list which was unsplash pixabay
pixels again i could type in something
like
texture and come in here and these are
all
creative common images that you can use
for free
and they're really large typically and
i'm just going to start building out
assets from this maybe i'll
type in my chalkboard right
and i'm going to find a chalkboard
texture here or maybe it's chalkboard
texture let's see what that pulls
um and always keep in mind that you
don't have to just key you know like if
i want a black and white texture of a
chalkboard and this is let's say blue
and white
and i think that texture might work i
can always make this black and white
right it doesn't have to be
perfect to begin with it just won't you
just want to have
different aspects in it that you're
attracted to
i also really enjoy free pick and for
some reason free pick
is not working today at the time of this
recording here we go it's working now
i also have a subscription so free pick
is great um you can come in here you can
download assets
a good variety of assets sometimes
you'll you're going to have to credit
the creator unless you have
a membership once you have a membership
here
you can download premium assets as well
which have these crowns
these are not going to be available to
people who don't have memberships
but you can download premium assets the
free assets and you don't have to credit
the creator
okay so i love free pick a lot i love
envato elements a lot for
affordable memberships for assets i've
also got turbo squid here this is great
for
3d models really great stuff here
if i need to use anything for 3d models
i'm going to come here to turbo squid
cg trader same kind of deal
very affordable models i should also
mention in envato elements here
there is a really cool section here
called 3d and let's just say for
whatever reason i want to use this bike
wheel
well i can view a 360 degree render of
this bike
and i can spin it around to the angle i
want
for my style frame and i can download
this angle which is really cool
i can even download the shadow if i want
to so that's something i use sometimes
as well
and that's pretty much it so these are
some sites like i said there's also
pixabay this is a great one
for downloading photos and
video and there's also pixels which i
really like a lot as well
if i can get it to load up here there's
pixels really nice imagery
as well the next thing i'm going to do
is i'm going to categorize all of the
images i download
into a folder structure just to keep
things
nice and tidy and i told you we're going
to do two concepts we're going to do two
different style frames
obviously both style frames are in in
the style that i like to create
but they're going to be two different
types of images and you're going to see
in the next video
what i mean by that so for concept one
um
it's a little bit more detailed and
concept two is a little more simpler
which you can see here why it's not
divided into all these different folders
here
because it is a simpler concept so we'll
talk about concept one here in just a
second but concept two we'll start with
and concept two
i want to go based on some inspiration
images i saw
i want to go with like a newspaper type
style frame
okay and i can see it in my head i just
see these different
newspaper clippings kind of floating in
3d space
and some lights and shadows and some
type so what i'm going to do is i pull
in a lot of these different
images i found a lot of these on google
and again i use my search tools
and i've found just different
newspaper clippings you know i may or
may not use these
you never know i'm looking at things
like the images i'm looking at the text
the headlines the titles of the papers
um you know that kind of stuff this is a
really nice one i like i'm really
drawn to this it's also got some nice
texture to it
what else we have here the next one
we've got war on the horizon
that's really nice up in here it's a
little bit uh
textured too textured for for my taste
but we can probably still work with it
what we have next we've got the kansas
city times
this is great great headline great
images
this one is really cool because as the
extra
headline war is over now it is blurry
right this is a lower quality image but
i think we can make this work
we will see though again from the kansas
city times us-78c
shut down weights c showdown weights
very cool this is a great image
really like that's defiance really nice
uh next we've got a folder here and in
this folder this is one that i
downloaded
from i believe free pick which is why i
have the premium license here
saying like hey you don't have to give
credit but this is something i
downloaded
with the idea that maybe i'd create my
own newspaper
and these are made so you can plug in
your own images and things like that
and then we've got although now looking
at that
i don't know why it's oh okay we've got
an eps because say a jpeg
you can't open up and really change this
in eps
you can and then we've got two more this
is really nice
and oh this is really really cool too i
like this one a lot
so that is for concept two concept two
is going to be what we're gonna call
our newspaper
concept and then for concept one we've
got
imagery that i've downloaded and
classified into these different
categories we've got clouds
i thought it'd be cool to maybe use
clouds as like an overlay with like the
u2 spy plane
because we are going to be using the spy
plane
we've got fingerprints we've got some
imagery here
png jpeg
and another jpeg really like these last
two
uh typically so like for for me
personally this
is too vector based looking now it may
work for whatever
um you know for other designers but for
me i typically stay away
away from vector-based artwork that is
you know illustrate ai files and eps
files
because it looks too crisp and digital
to me
i like jpeg and png
files to have that that imperfection to
them
right we've also got some maps um i
downloaded this map this ai
map um because it's can be scaled up
and we can use it you know infinitely
scaled there's an eps of it there's also
a jpeg
there's a vintage world map that i
downloaded as well
and you know i i spent several hours
just downloading all of these different
assets
which i don't want you know i didn't
want to show you that whole process
because it's a tedious process you can
take
you know you should always spend on the
concepting stage i recommend that you
spend
half a day just
a half to full day just concepting if
you have the time to do it just coming
up with
what your initial ideas are going to be
and pulling assets right
pulling assets is so important because
this is an
awesome image pulling these assets are
really going to help me drive my design
i'm going to look at okay what have i
pulled and how can i make this work in
my design
i don't like this one so much because
you can tell it is it's been digitized
at some point
it's very vector that's an awesome image
with the color and the contrast
that's a very awesome image as well
i've seen this used in different uh
in magazines and things like that we've
also got some guns i downloaded
that would be kind of interesting to use
possibly
what missiles we have here for missiles
i'm just hitting the space bar i'm on a
mac like i said
that's a really cool image there and i'm
also thinking when i see these images
what
what can i cut out what can be cut out
and used by itself i could cut out here
you know and around here and around this
building and have this be its own thing
i could just cut out the
the fire here in the missile and have
the missile be its own thing
uh this is cool when i downloaded it i
didn't realize it was a lego
image right so you can if you look
closely it's a lego image which is
pretty funny i downloaded it
but if it was very small
in our style frame it's like a very
small asset you could probably get away
with using a lego image
right um here's another really cool
missile that i could
come in and kind of cut this out and
have it be its own element
i don't have to use this background
image or the sky
here's a really cool time lapse image of
a missile coming out of the ground
and flying high really cool
and then we've got planes here inside of
the military we've got
um some planes here's a youtube spy
plane
a really cool angle there's another
really cool angle
and then i believe i cut yeah i cut that
one out i just used a very simple
um i selected the
plane with a quick selection tool
and cut it out so you can see it's got
some jagged edges here
but you know it doesn't have to be
perfect it just depends if the plane is
going to be
in our face very big then you want a
really nice cutout i'm going to use
something like the pen tool to do that
if not i'm going to use a quick
selection tool this is
interesting now we have to run into
issues where this this wing is cut off
here so maybe this is an asset that's at
the bottom of our frame
um or it's turned sideways or something
like that but something we have to keep
in mind
um and here's another u2 spy plane so
those were really easy to find
and that is under military i've also got
miscellaneous here which this is just
like an oil rig
crane type of setup i thought it was
cool
maybe we can use it we've got paper lots
of different paper here
we've got dirty paper these are images
i've got a
huge texture library that i keep at all
times on a hard drive
and because i use a lot of the same type
of textures over and over again right
it's part of my style
so i like to keep those things in a in a
handy folder structure that i can come
back to
if i need to pull assets so this is a
really nice paper texture
it's not too over the top it's got some
really nice texture to it
again here's another one a lot of times
with these texture elements
it's easy to go over the top and find
things that look
too intense and they can be too intense
and overpowering in our style frame
design
so it's all about layering right it's
all about layering these different
elements together
here's some more interesting paper
pieces these are cutouts
with alpha channels pretty cool stuff
we've got tapes all different types of
tape
we've got these are all png files
so again we can overlay these on our
design assets we can do transfer modes
we could cut out the white around
them if we needed to just really cool
assets
uh some clear tape here i think maybe i
downloaded these
from envato elements
uh which was you know easy to do that's
what i like about these different sites
with stock media is you can quickly
download assets
and have access to them so i'm using
dropbox
and these are not synced to my computer
so as soon as i do that and open them up
here you go these are some assets i got
from
my buddy ryan thygard for a texture pack
we were working on
uh so those could come in handy um i
believe
these tapes down here might have been
from ryan as well
let's take a look at these really
quickly here
yeah these are from ryan as well he's a
photographer and he's a
great asset for textures
so those are tapes we've also got just
textures
downloaded these are from freepik.com
really really dig this texture a lot
it's really cool
definitely can see it being used some
crumpled
sheet paper again this is like
you know some graph i talked about grids
and graphs that's why i downloaded this
um what do we have here this is an
interesting texture this could be over
too overpowering i do have to be careful
about that one it could be too
overpowering
tiled stones this is one that's really
cool i'm definitely going to use this
one
um i like the the texture in the black
as well as the lines the vertical and
the horizontal lines
super cool stuff and then when we get
into actual countries because this is
the cold war
this is a really cool picture of kennedy
now it is low res and you can really see
the loss of detail here but it's a
really cool image
american flag it's not ideal because
it's tinted
on the yellow side but we could always
correct that or we could try and use
that tent
in our image reagan us president very
involved in the cold war helped to bring
it to an end
and then we've got a tank here
which i think i put in the usa folder
but i don't actually know i believe it's
maybe not a usa
tank we've got some ussr
uh the flag so union
soviet union stalin
which i put that hem down in the assets
socialism
uh this was a really cool image um if
for anything it just inspired me like
i've seen a lot of designer
designers create um imagery that looks
like this where there's a bank of tvs
basically
and they're showing all different types
of imagery so i can either use this for
a style frame as like a base
or i can just use it to inspire me
that's why it's there
and that's it that is concept one and
we've talked about concept two so
concept one
is going to be more of a collage is how
i see it a collage
um style frame
so that is how you
concept a a basic style frame design and
how you start pulling assets
you get a basic idea in your head of
what you want to
to show or you base it off the creative
brief you start researching
what type of imagery would be involved
with that what kind of creative
reference do you want to use to inspire
you
then you pull assets you write down
assets of what you
like to use you start researching those
assets and pulling those assets and as
you're doing that
you're going to find that you're going
to find even more assets
that that relate to what you're trying
to design it's going to
start taking you down almost a rabbit
hole of different assets don't overdo it
limit yourself to assets i don't know
how many i've got here
but it's not too many maybe it's 30
maybe 30 to 40. i wouldn't go over 50
assets for two style frames because we
are doing two separate style frames here
so that's how you get your concept and
going
okay so that was fun now you're clear
about how to concept and create digital
assets for your style frames and the
next
big question is how do you use these
concepting techniques and directions to
actually
build out the style frames hands down
this is the most important aspect of
style frame designing
if you can't lay out the style frames in
an interesting and beautiful way
then you will not be successful in style
frame design
and this doesn't have to mean you have
to work really hard at it it's about
working
smart at it and it's about getting a
better result
for as little as pos as little
work as possible in my opinion it's it's
very possible okay it doesn't have to be
challenging
so how do you lay out assets in style
from design
that's exactly what i'm going to show
you
in the next video and it's going to blow
your mind i
guarantee it's you're going to see how
easy it is so before we go today i want
to hear from you
okay i'd love to hear from you tell me
what would life
be like look like for you if you could
easily concept style frames if you take
what you learned today
and apply it what is life going to look
like for you
how will life be different when you lay
down that solid foundation for style
frame design how is it going to make
your motion design life easier let me
know in the comments below
and i'm going to read every one of these
comments i always do and i'm going to
respond to as many of these comments as
possible i promise you
and also if you found this video useful
because this is a limited time video i'm
going to ask you please share it on
facebook
share it on twitter share it to your
social media groups
so what you've learned here today is a
simple process for creating
design assets for concepting it's a game
changer
in helping you design pro level style
frames it's a key
step it's key step number one along the
way in reaching your goal
of becoming a style frame designer and
as motion designers
we all need to know how to design okay
what you're going to learn in this
workshop puts you on the path to getting
to become a pro level design motion
designer okay
next up we'll talk all about how to
layout the design assets
assets in a process i call photo bashing
and it's fun i can't wait to see in the
next video
[Music]
you